oh my god our average Joe isn't exactly
on a gyro joyride you got to get your
hand okay keyboard John Oh
how many letters are in the words fight
science you need to type the number of
letters onto the keyboard not not the
word how many letters okay without elite
Special Operations training he doesn't
have a technique to battle spatial
disorientation in what month is Memorial
Day
John focus on the keyboard focus it
starting not feel ya know like now you
can tell he's actually studying nothing
to be also good his heart rates starting
to increase this breathing rate start to
increase I'm gonna put this closer yeah
you might want to have that close by the
average respiratory rate is 12 breaths
per minute John is up to 30 if he
exceeds 40 breaths per minute he could
hyperventilate and blackout hi so was i
I need to stop you stop your head stuff
stop it okay Oh after four minutes on
the gyroscope our average Joe calls it
quits we were gonna have him there the
full nine minutes like we had the other
soldiers but we had to call it quits a
little bit early and I'm glad we did
because look at the shape he's in he's
spun out of his shoes Oh watch your head
watch John is exhibiting classic signs
of spatial disorientation
the inner ear is considered the organ of
equilibrium each canal is filled with
fluid containing microscopic hairs that
act as motion sensors as John's body
rotates this hair movement sends a
signal to the brain indicating that the
head is turned but as the gyroscope
constantly changes direction in speed
the hairs don't have time to catch up
with the body's movement as a result of
this delay they send erroneous
information to the brain about the
body's position the eyes also help to
maintain balance when the I can't anchor
itself on a fixed focal point it has no
frame of reference the optical nerve
sends a message to the brain that the
body is off-balance even when John's
body stops rotating his over stimulated
sensory system continues sending
inaccurate information to his brain for
several minutes he experiences the
sensation of spinning called vertigo
this can exacerbate his spatial
disorientation causing dizziness
excessive sweating and vomiting it's not
exactly a winning recipe one of the
tricks of this thing is don't beat
yourself before you start he's
complaining about the straps being too
tight he didn't know where to put his
hand he a lot of anxiety about well how
long am I gonna be in here you have to
go in with the right mindset
just enjoy it laugh about it because
it'll always be worse uh being average
has never felt worse